matt is in Raleigh hi Matt welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave how's it
going better than I deserve sir what's
up all right well I've been through
Financial Peace University twice now I'm
trying to get myself motivated but the
big thing is I've been trying to get my
wife motivated too
she's been doing your class just kind of
understands but everything that I've
tried she says I don't know if she's
afraid or what I I'm looking for a yeah
ask her ask her yeah why don't you want
us to go in with money because if we
went with money we would be able to
change our family tree we'd be able to
travel we'd be able to do all these
things why don't you want to do that
yeah I've tried bringing that up she
she's a very compulsive defendant and so
it's been very it's been very hard for
me to try to eat just bring up money
with her because she's afraid of the
budget you know she's not afraid the
budget she's very afraid of the word no
and she's afraid you're trying to
control her but what if she believed in
something big enough that she
intentionally handled the money on
purpose that allowed her to spend but
only what she said she would spend
rather than impulsively spending how old
is she she is 25 that she'd grow up as a
spoiled brat
she she I think pretty much so is he her
daddy she wanted her that her daddy give
her everything she ever wanted her mom
did okay so she's never heard the word
no so part of growing up is learning to
hear the word know and it's learning to
tell yourself no by the way that's being
a grown up adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
ouch so I think the two of you probably
need to sit down with a good marriage
counselor because I think you're headed
towards the wall fast if you guys don't
get on the same page with your emotional
maturity and your relational maturity
this scares me too
you guys need to sit down the marriage
counselor immediately and it's not a
financial problem this is a self-control
problem this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]